So I just showed you that empirically
the likelihood will converge, but
theoretically it can also be proved
that EM algorithm with converge to a
local maximum.
So here is just the illustration of
what happened an A detailed explanation
this.
Require more.
Knowledge about some of the
inequalities that we haven't really
covered yet.
So here what you see is on the X
dimension.
We have set up value.
This is the parameter that we left on
the Y axis.
We see the likelihood function.
So this curve is reaching or like
roller function, right?
So this one.
And this is the one that we hope to
maximize an we hope to find a set of
value at this point to maximize this.
But in the case of mixture model, we
cannot easily find the analytical
solution to the problem.
So we have to resolve a numerical
algorithm.
An EM algorithm is such an algorithm.
It's a Hill climb algorithm that would
mean you start with some random guess.
Let's say you start from here.
That's your starting point and then you
try to improve this by moving this to
another point where you can have a
higher like recorder.
So that's the idea of Hill climbing.
Any in the MRI was the way we achieve
this is to do two things.
First will fix a lower bound of
likelihood function, so this is the
lower bound you can see here.
An once we fit the lower bound we can
then maximise the lower bound and of
course the reason why this works is
because the lower bound is much easier
to optimize so we know our current gas
is here an by maximizing the lower
bound will move this point to the top
two here.
I.
And that we can then map to the
original like role function.
We find this point.
Be cause it's a lower bound, we are
guaranteed to improve this gas.
Right, because we improve our lower
bound and then the original lighter
Holder curve which is above this lower
bound will definitely be improved as
well.
I so we already know it's improving the
lower bound, so we definitely improve
this original like record function
which is above this lower bound.
So in our example, the current gas is
parameter value given by the current
generation and then the next guest is
the RE estimated parameter values.
From this illustration you can see the
next gas is always better than the
current gas unless it has reached the
maximum where it would be stuck there.
So the two would be equal.
So the E step is basically to compute
this lower bound.
And we don't direct it, just computed
this likely or function, but we
computed the latent variable values
and.
These are basically part of this lower
bound.
This helps determine the lower bound
the M step on the other hand, is to
maximize the lower bound.
It allows us to move parameters to a
new point.
And that's why EML is gone.
The little converge to a local maximum.
Now, as you can imagine, when we have
many local Maxima, we also have to
repeat the EML with multiple times in
order to figure out which one is the
actual global maximum.
And this actually in general is a
difficult problem in numerical
optimization.
So here for example, how do we start
from here?
Then we gradually just climb up to this
top, so that's not optimal, and we'd
like to climb up all the way to here.
So the only way to climb up to this
here.
This will start from somewhere here or
Right so.
In the EM algorithm, we generally would
have to start from different points or
have some other way to determine a good
initial starting point.
To summarize, in this lecture we
introduce the EM algorithm.
This is a general algorithm for
computing.
Maximum regular is made of all kinds of
mixture models.
So not just for our simple mixture
model and so here climbing algorithm so
can only converge it or local maximum,
and it would depend on initial points.
The general idea is that we will have
two steps to improve the estimate of
parameters in the E step.
We roughly all augmenting our data by
predicting values of useful hidden
variables that we would use to simplify
the estimation.
In our case, this is the distribution
that has been used to generate the
world.
In the end step, then would exploit
such augmented data, which would make
it easier to estimate the distribution
to improve the estimate of parameters.
Here improve is guaranteed in terms of
the likelihood function.
Note that it's not necessary that we
will have a stable converged parameter
values, even though the likelihood
function is insured to increase.
There are some properties that have to
be satisfied in order for the
parameters also too.
Convert it to some stable value.
Now he thought data augmentation is
done probabilistically.
That means we're not going to just say
exactly what's the value of a hidden
variable, but we're going to have a
probability distribution over the
possible values of these hidden
variables, so this causes a split of
counts of events probabilistically and
in our case, will split the world
counts between the two distributions.